Nói hay nổi rửi của cô ngồi là cái quà
Trời ơi, các cả thiết quốc của người ta phải gắn rồi đó
Tôi nhỏ cụ thệ
Những chỉ tiêu hồi ngọc cắn liền với tăng trở, tìm tây sau hồi của điều phương
Cụ ngần xách trên điệu bà
Rồi, ở cơ sở, nó là chính quyền điều phương hay cấp
Vất hành đi đây nào
Hồng chỉ kết thường, tất trung vào 1 năm rồi, đang giả anh chỗ nào làm tốt
Tên thử hợp
Còn những phương rất cụ thệ mà chúng ta đang làm, hồi hợp qua
Bí dụ như cách điều phương, các có cắt xả biên rồi, đang xây rất cắt trường
Hồn thành các cái chường
Thậu ngồi chú liên cấp, các bạn sạm biên rồi
Chúc ta có nên, anh ra, để có thể
Hẹn tưởng, kịt tơi như nơi nào làm
Đúng tên rồi, và có chết lợp vụ quà hay không
Rồi, kế hoạch 5 năm trong ngày
Ngày đêm, để tìm kiếm, để quý tập, để giả định dành tính hợp kỗ lì gì
Chúc ta phải bị vừa một số
Lực vừa, có cấp cơ sở
Nguyên rất và thử nghiệp, có những cái đống khóc, giữ quà, tích cử